Entonces, ¿quién son yo?
Generalmente contesto a la gente, cuando me preguntan, "Qué es lo que haces?
Digo, "Hago hardware,"
porque digamos que convenientemente abarca todo lo que hago.
Y recientemente dije eso a un inversionista de riesgo en un
evento en el Valle, y respondió, "Qué pintoresco."
(Risas)
Y realmente estaba asombrado.
Y yo debí haber dicho algo inteligente.
Y ahora que he tenido algo de tiempo para pensarlo,
Hubiera dicho, "Bueno, sabes,
si miramos los siguientes cien años
y hemos visto todos estos problemas de los últimos días,
la mayoría de los grandes retos -- agua limpia, energía limpia --
y son intercambiables en algunos aspectos --
y materiales más limpios y funcionales --
todos para mi parecen ser problemas de "hardware".
Esto no quiere decir que debemos ignorar al "software",
o a la información, o a la computación.
Y esto es, de hecho, lo que voy a tratar de contarles.
Entonces, esta plática va a ser sobre cómo hacemos las cosas
y de cómo van las nuevas maneras en las que haremos las cosas en el futuro.
Ahora, TED te envía mucho correo basura si eres un conferencista
de "haz esto, haz lo otro" y lléname todos estos formularios,
y nunca sabes realmente cómo te van a describir,
me llego a mi escritorio que me iban a presentar como un futurista.
Siempre me ha puesto nervioso el término futurista,
porque está destinado al fracaso porque realmente no puedes predecirlo.
y me estaba riendo de esto con unos colegas muy inteligentes que tengo,
y dije, "saben, si tuvieran que hablar sobre el futuro, ¿qué es?"
y George Homsey, un gran tipo, dijo, "Ah, el futuro es increíble.
Es mucho mas extraño de lo que piensas.
Vamos a reprogramas las bacterias en tu estomago,
y vamos a hacer que tus desechos huelan a hierba buena
(Risas)
Pues, pueden pensar que esto es una locura,
pero hay algunas cosas muy asombrosas que están pasando
que hacen esto posible
Bueno, esto no es mi trabajo, pero es el trabajo de unos buenos amigo en el MIT.
Esto se llama el registro de partes biológicas estándar.
Está liderado por Drew Endy y Tom Knight
y otras personas muy, muy listas.
Básicamente, lo que están haciendo es viendo la biología como un sistema programable.
Literalmente, piensen en las proteínas como subrutinas
que pueden enlazar para ejecutar un programa.
Ahora, esto se está tornando en una idea interesante.
Éste es un diagrama de estados. Es una computadora extremadamente sencilla.
Éste es un contador de dos "bits"
Eso es esencialmente el computo equivalente de dos contactos de luz.
Y esto esta siendo construido por un grupo de estudiantes en Zurich
para un concurso de diseño en biología.
Y de los resultados de la misma competencia el año pasado,
un equipo de estudiantes de la Universidad de Texas programó bacterias
para que pudieran detectar luz y se cambiaran encendido y apagado.
Esto es interesante en el sentido que ahora se puede
hacer enunciados "si por lo tanto" en materiales, en la estructura.
Esto es una tendencia bastante interesante,
Porque vivíamos en un mundo donde todos decían fácilmente,
forma sigue a la función, pero creo que he crecido en un mundo
-- escucharon a Neil Gershenfeld ayer,
Yo estaba en un laboratorio asociado con el suyo -- donde es realmente un mundo
donde la información define a la forma y la función.
He pasado seis años pensando sobre eso,
pero para demostrar el poder del arte sobre la ciencia --
éste es precisamente uno de los dibujos que escribo. Se llaman "Cómo-dibujos"
Trabajo con un dibujante extraordinario llamando Nick Dragotta.
Me tomó seis años en el MIT,
y como así de tantas páginas para describir qué es lo que estaba haciendo,
y a él le tomo una hoja. Y ésta es nuestra musa Tucker.
Él es un niño muy interesante --- y su hermana, Celine--
y lo que está haciendo aquí
está observando los auto-ensambles de su tazón de cereal "Cheerios".
y por cierto se pueden programar los auto-ensambles de cosas,
así que empieza con las orillas con chocolate,
cambiando la hidrofobia y la hidrofilia.
En teoría, si programas estas cosas lo suficientemente,
deberías poder hacer algo muy interesante
y hacer estructuras muy complejas
En este caso, ha hecho una auto-réplica de una estructura 3D compleja
Y esto es lo que pensé por mucho tiempo,
porque así es como actualmente hacemos cosas.
Esto es una tabla de silicio, y esencialmente
es solo un grupo de capas de dos dimensiones, de alguna manera apiladas
Lo importante es -- saben, la gente dirá,
[confuso] abajo y aproximadamente 65 nanómetros ahora.
En la derecha, eso es una "radiolara".
Esto es un organismo unicelular ubicuo en el océano
y tiene características de aproximadamente 20 nanómetros,
y estructura compleja en tres dimensiones
Podríamos hacer mucho más con computadoras y cosas en general
si supiéramos cómo construir cosas de esta manera.
El secreto a la biología es, construye computación
en la manera que hace las cosas. Entonces esta pequeña cosa, "polimerasa",
es esencialmente una supercomputadora diseñada para replicar DNA.
Y esta ribosoma, es otra pequeña computadora
que ayuda en la traducción de proteínas.
Pensé sobre esto
en el sentido de que es grandioso construir sobre materiales biológicos,
pero ¿podemos hacer cosas similares?
¿Cómo podemos obtener un comportamiento auto replicable?
¿Podemos obtener complejas estructuras 3D que se ensamblan automáticamente
en sistemas inorgánicos?
Porque hay algunas ventajas en los sistemas inorgánicos,
como semiconductores de mayor velocidad, etcétera.
Bueno, esto es algo de mi trabajo
de cómo haces un sistema auto replicable autónomo.
Y esto es, podríamos decir que la revancha de Babbage.
Éstas son pequeñas computadoras mecánicas.
Éstas son máquinas de cinco estados.
Y, esto son tres interruptores alineados.
En un estado neutral, no se unirían.
Ahora, si hacemos una línea de estos, una línea de bits,
podrán replicarse.
Entonces comenzamos con blanco, azul, azul, blanco.
Eso codifica, eso ahora se copiará. De uno vienen dos,
y de dos salen tres.
Y pues se obtiene un tipo de sistema de replicado.
Realmente fue trabajo de Lionel Penrose,
padre de Roger Penrose, el chavo de los mosaicos.
Realizó mucho trabajo en los años sesenta,
y mucha de su teoría lógica quedo empolvada
y conforme avanzamos a la revolución digital de las computadores, está regresando.
Ahora voy mostrar el manos libre, autónomo auto replicación.
ahora hemos rastreado en el vídeo la línea de entrada,
que fue, verde, verde, amarillo, amarillo, verde.
Los colocamos en una mesa de hockey de aire.
Saben, la ciencia avanzada usa las mesas de hockey de aire --
(Risas)
-- y si observan esto por suficiente tiempo se van a marear,
pero lo que realmente están viendo son copias de la línea original
emergiendo de las partes que tenemos aquí.
Entonces tenemos líneas de bits que se están replicando autónomamente.
Pero, ¿por qué querríamos replicar líneas de bits?
Bueno, resulta que la biología tiene un muy interesante meme,
puedes tomar una línea, que sea conveniente de copiar,
y lo puedes desdoblar en estructuras en tres dimensiones arbitrarias.
Estaba tratando, saben, de tomar la versión de ingeniero:
¿Podemos construir sistemas mecánicos en materiales inorgánicos
que hagan la misma cosa?
Lo que voy a mostrar aquí es que podemos hacer una figura en dos dimensiones --
la B -- ensamblada de líneas de componentes
que siguen reglas extremadamente sencillas.
Y el punto de seguir reglas extremadamente sencillas ,
y el increíble estado simple de las máquinas en diseños previos,
fue que no necesitas lógica digital para hacer computación.
Y de esta manera puedes escalar cosas mucho mas pequeñas que microchips.
Entonces puedes literalmente usar estos pequeños componentes en un proceso de ensamblado.
Niel Gershenfeld les mostró este video el miércoles, creo,
pero se los mostraré de nuevo.
Esto es literalmente una secuencia ilustrada de los mosaicos.
Cada diferente color tiene su propia polaridad magnética,
y la secuencia está únicamente especificando la estructura resultante.
Ahora, espero, que los que sepan algo de teoría gráfica
puedan ver eso, y estarán satisfechos
que esto también puede hacer estructuras en tres dimensiones arbitrarias,
y de hecho, saben, pueden tomar un perro, y esculpirlo
y después re-ensamblarlo para que sea una línea
que se desdoblará de una secuencia. Y ahora
puedo definir ese objeto tridimensional como una secuencia de bits.
Pues saben, es un mundo muy interesante
cuando comienzan a ver el mundo de forma diferente,
y el universo es ahora un compilador,
Y estoy pensando, saben, ¿qué son los programas
para programar el universo físico?
Y ¿cómo pensamos sobre materiales y estructura,
como problemas de información y computación?
No sólo dónde adjuntas un mico controlador en esa esquina,
pero que la estructura y los mecanismos son la lógica, son las computadoras.
Una vez que se absorbe totalmente esta filosofía ,
Comencé a ver los problemas algo diferentes.
Con el universo como una computadora,
puedes ver esta gota de agua
como si hubiera realizado las computaciones.
Colocas una serie de condiciones de frontera, como gravedad,
la tensión superficial, densidad, etcétera, y presiones ejecutar,
y mágicamente, el universo produce una lente redonda perfecta.
Pues, esto se aplica al problema
-- hay medio billón a un billón de personas en el mundo
que no tiene acceso a lentes baratas.
Entonces ¿puedes hacer una máquina
que pueda hacer lentes de prescripción rápidamente en el sitio?
Ésta es una maquina en la que literalmente defines condiciones de frontera.
Si es circular, haces lentes esféricas.
Si es elíptica, haces lentes para astigmatismo.
Le colocas una membrana y le aplicas presión ..
y esto es parte del programa extra.
Y literalmente con solamente estas dos entradas --
la forma de tu condición de frontera y presión --
se pueden definir un numero infinito de lentes
esto cubre todo el rango de error refractivo humano,
de menos 12 a mas ocho dioptrías, hasta cuatro dioptrías cilíndricas
Y después, literalmente, viertes un monómero.
Saben, hará un Julia Childs aquí.
Esto es tres minutos de luz ultravioleta.
E invertimos la presión en la membrana
una vez que lo cocinas. Lo levantas.
He visto este video, pero no sé si va a terminar bien.
(Risas)
Entonces inviertes esto. Esta película es muy antigua,
y con los nuevos prototipos, las dos superficies son flexibles,
pero esto mostrara la idea.
Ahora has terminado el lente, y literalmente la liberas.
Este es el modelo "Yves Klein", para el año pasado, saben, la forma de los lentes.
Y pueden ver que esto tiene una prescripción suave de aproximadamente menos dos dioptrías.
Y mientras lo giro contra este lado, verán que tiene un cilindro,
y que esto estaba programado dentro de él --
literalmente dentro de la física del sistema.
Entonces, esto de pensar en la estructura como computación
y la estructura como información nos lleva a otras cosas, como ésta.
Esto es algo en lo que mi gente en el Laboratorio SQUID
están trabajando, llamado cuerda electrónica.
Literalmente, piensas en una cuerda. Tiene estructuras muy complejas en el tejido.
Y bajo ninguna carga, es una estructura.
Bajo una distinta carga, es una estructura diferente. Y realmente puedes explotar eso
poniendo un numero muy pequeño
de fibras conductoras para realmente hacerlo un sensor.
Ahora esto es una cuerda que sabe cuanto peso esta cargando
en cualquier punto particular en la cuerda.
Nada más por pensar en la física del mundo,
materiales como computadoras,
puedes empezar a hacer cosas como éstas.
Voy a continuar.
Supongo que solo voy a algunas cosas de manera informal
que pienso sobre esto.
Una de las cosas que realmente estoy interesando en este momento, es cómo,
si realmente están pensando en el universo como una computadora,
cómo hacemos las cosas desde un punto de vista general,
y ¿cómo podríamos compartir la manera que hacemos las cosas de un punto de vista general.
de la misma manera que se comparte hardware de código abierto?
Y muchas conferencias aquí han expuesto los beneficios
de tener mucha gente para ver los problemas,
compartir la información y trabajar en las cosas conjuntamente.
Pues, un ventaja de ser humano es que nos movemos en tiempo linear,
y a menos que Lisa Randall cambie esto,
nos seguiremos moviendo en tiempo lineal.
Esto significa que cualquier cosa que hagas, o construyas,
produces una secuencia de pasos --
y creo que Lego en los 70s dio en el clavo,
y lo hicieron de una manera elegante.
Pero pueden mostrar cómo construir cosas en secuencia.
Entonces, estoy pensando, cómo podemos generalizar
la manera que hacemos todo tipo de cosas,
y acaban con un tipo así, ¿correcto?
Y creo que esto aplica de forma muy amplia, digamos que en muchos conceptos.
Saben, Cameron Sinclair ayer dijo,
"¿Cómo puedo hacer que todos colaboren en diseñar
globalmente para hacer residencias para la humanidad?"
Y si han visto a Amy Smith,
ella habla de cómo poner estudiantes al MIT
a trabajar con comunidades en Haití.
Y creo que debemos redefinir y repensar
cómo definimos estructura y materiales y en ensamble de cosas,
para que realmente podamos compartir información
en cómo hacer las cosas de una manera mas profunda
y construir basándonos en las fuentes de código para estructura de los demás.
No sé cómo exactamente hacer esto todavía
pero, saben, es algo en lo que constantemente se ha pensado.
Y, saben, esto lleva a preguntas
como, ¿es esto un compilador? ¿Es una subrutina?
Cosas interesantes como éstas.
Tal vez me estoy poniendo algo abstracto, pero ya saben
esto es parecido -- volviendo a nuestros personajes de cómic --
esto es como el universo, o una vista diferente del universo
que creo que va a ser muy predominante en el futuro --
desde la biotecnología al ensamble de materiales. Fue grandioso escuchar a Bill Joy.
Están comenzando a invertir en ciencia de materiales,
pero éstas son novedades en ciencia de materiales.
¿Como ponemos información y estructura real en nuevas ideas,
y ver el mundo de una manera distinta? Y no será código binario
que define las computadoras del universo --
es como una computadora analógica.
Pero definitivamente es una nuevo punto de vista interesante.
He ido muy lejos. Al menos eso parece.
Probablemente tenga unos minutos para preguntas,
o puedo mostrar -- creo que dijeron que hacia cosas extremas
en la introducción, por lo tanto tendré que explicarlo.
Tal vez lo haré con este breve video.
Esto es realmente una papalote de 3,000 pies cuadrados (279 metros cuadrados)
que es una superficie mínima de energía.
Si retornamos a la gota, de nuevo,
pensando en el universo de una forma distinta
El papalote está diseñado por un tipo llamado Dave Kulp.
Y para qué quieres un papalote de 3,000 pies cuadrados?
Esto es un papalote del tamaño de tu casa.
Y lo quieres para remolcar barcos muy rápido.
Pues he estado trabajando en esto por un poco,
con un par de otros tipos.
Pero, saben, ésta es otra manera de ver ---
si nos ponemos abstractos de nuevo,
esta es una estructura que esta definida por la física del universo
Lo podrías colgar como una sábana,
pero de nuevo, la computación de toda la física
nos da la forma aerodinámica.
Y entones podrías casi doblar la velocidad de tu barco
con sistemas así. Y, esto es un aspecto interesante del futuro.
(Aplausos)